hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm going to talk to
you about my plan to become a
multi-billionaire now just so you can
understand how much a billion is I am
way off being a multi-billionaire at the
moment I'm 32 years old I'm a
multi-millionaire but I'm way off a
multi-billionaire I'm not even close to
a billion so a billion pounds is a,
million that's not making a th000
million my business Mak Mak about 1.5
million a month turnover it's not making
a billion it's having a
billion net worth billion pounds cash or
billion pounds invested so if you sold
everything and paid off all your debts
you'd be left with a billion a billions
a thousand million I worked out recently
that if I did pretty much nothing else
semi-retired I would become a
multi-billionaire before the age that I
die assuming that I live a long life now
nothing's guaranteed I might die
tomorrow but my plan and my business is
set to make me a multi-billionaire and I
wanted to share for the very first time
ever publicly how my business is set up
and how it's structured to make me a
multi-billionaire before the age that I
die becoming a billionaire was never the
plan if you look at most billionaires
they're not pushing to try and make more
money if you want to make you know ,000
you might be able to go out bang make
quick, tonight no problem but you're not
going to make a billion pounds quick to
make billions of pounds is about having
a very valuable product or service and
about impacting a million people believe
it or not I'm not going to become a
multi-billionaire from my property
Investments Ain that interesting so how
am I going to become a multi-billionaire
if it's not from my property Investments
when that's pretty much all I do it's
certainly not going to be from my
courses I've lost more money as a
trainer more years than I've actually
made money you know if you look on the
Sunday Times rich list there ain't no
one on the Sunday Times rich list Rich
from selling courses it's a pretty tough
business certainly not going to make me
a billionaire not going to make a
billion pound from deal sourcing or rent
to rents so how is it going to happen
how am I already set and structured and
this is a business that is making a lot
of money and it's something that people
they're aware of the business but if you
knew the numbers it would probably shock
you so I reveal the numbers and what am
I doing this video I made a deliberate
decision about 10 15 years ago when I
first started having a bit of success in
property and business that I was going
to hold my cards very open I wasn't
going to hold my cards close to my chest
because I've noticed that a lot of poor
people who are just dreamers and
thinkers they're like really paranoid
that people are going to steal their
idea or they don't want to look stupid
and say they're going to do something
and then not do it and get egg on their
face but if you actually look at
successful companies like even like
McDonald's their entire business plan
and how they is all publicly available
on the internet for free their business
plan like billionaires aren't worried
about people stealing their ideas Elon
Musk isn't worried that someone's going
to build a spaceship and go to space
before him he'll talk about his vision
and also can't for speak into existence
what's the business well the business is
compound interest my uh lending business
is the one that's going to make me a
multi-billionaire and I'll explain how I
saved up of my own money from property
and from my businesses and hard work I
saved up1 million and I'm loaning out at
the moment about a million pound a month
to my students we started about four
months ago so we've loaned 3.7 million
but in the next over the um the
financial year be it'll it'll be about
11 million that's how much we've got in
the kitty how's 11 measy million and you
might be thinking that's that's a lot of
money it is a lot of money but it ain't
a lot of money compared to a billion P
how's 11 me million going to make me a
multibillionaire even if I stopped
investing in property even if I even
sold all of my houses all my tenants
stopped paying me rent I closed down all
my businesses my agencies my training I
retired and just was quietly living in
my house and doing very very very little
my lending business Samuel leed's
Finance would be a multi billion pound
company I believe how I'm not even
charging High interest rates number one
people are queuing up to get money from
my finance company I could very easily
loan out1 million next week if I wanted
to the reason I'm only doing a million
pound a month is because I've only got
11 million and I want most people will
repay their loan after 12 months so
after 12 months my 11 million I'll have
got back that money with interest well
how much is that okay I charge when I
loan out money about 1% a month with a
1% entry and exit fee which covers admin
costs and after 6 months 1.5% a month so
on average when someone loans 100 Grand
and I capit at 100 Grand at the moment I
could give out so much more money I have
to cap it because I want to impact more
people if I got out a million pound a
pop for the development deals which I
could very easily do I can only help 11
people over the next 11 months cuz I've
only got 11 million I've only got 11
million for this so I'm capping it 100
Grand to be able to impact more people
but if the average loan that I give out
and I give out £1 million is getting 15%
net for me well 11 million times 15%
means that I will make
£11.65 million profit so when I get my1
million back it will not be 11 million
it will be
12.65 million this is the power of
compound interest what will I then do
with my 12.65 I will then reloan out
that's year one cuz if we do year two
I've now got
14.54 million that's year two what about
year 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 well 10 years in
now I'm only 32 so 42 now when I'm 42
that's now
44.5 million interesting what about
after 20 years 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 180
million I'm still 52 now it's beginning
to get exciting still nowhere near a
billion though what about another 10 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 oh my goodness now I'm
62 now it's almost a a billion pound now
it's 728 what about another 10 years 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 now it's almost 3
billion that's a multi-billion pound
company now and the average person at
the moment in this generation is what
living till 80 85 by the time I'm 80 if
I just keep doing nothing I'm not
actively finding deals I'm not all I'm
doing is is people are going out finds
coming to me if by the age of 80 I just
keep learning the money out reinvesting
the profits that'll be a 10 billion
pound net worth there's some pitfalls to
the business for a start we've not
talked about tax um we've also not
talked about the fact that it might be
that my finance company is not massively
in demand it might be that people don't
want I don't think the latter will
happen I think that the competition for
bridging F it's so hard to get bridging
Finance we're so quick like at our speed
and and how we operate I think there
there will be Dem man personally with
those interest rates he pretty
competitive didn't talk about tax but
you know we also didn't talk about we
cuz that's what the cricks were say oh
you didn't talk about this you didn't
talk you know what we also didn't talk
about we also didn't talk about the fact
that most bridging companies don't just
loan out their money most bridging
companies loan out other people's money
once I've got a proven track record with
my 11 million whats to stop me taking
money really cheap from other finance
companies and paying them 5% and loaning
it out at 12 13 14% now that's not even
compound that's huge leverage if you
combine leverage and compound that's how
you become a billionaire I'll become a
multi-billionaire just from compound
interest but I'll become a multi-
multi-billionaire maybe before the age
of 80 through compound and leverage so
that's the business that financially is
most exciting by a country mile I think
the first thing is if you want to be
let's say you want to be a millionaire I
see so many people I want to be a
millionaire okay well what's your plan
can you even comprehend it because if
you even got a realistic business plan
where you can see it even happening see
I didn't have that Thro to be a
billionaire if you asked me 5 years ago
how you going to become a billionaire
I'd have been like even if I scale up
what I'm doing I could work 10 times
harder and 10 times smarter and I'm
still never going to be a
multibillionaire with what I'm doing but
now I'm actually like okay yeah this is
going to happen so for you I mean look
it might be that money lending is
something that you isn't right for you
right now if you were 20 years old and
you had 100 Grand and you loaned it out
of 15% guarantee you'd be worth 100 Mil
in your in your lifetime if you started
with 100 Grand and you loan it out 15%
so you're going to get out all your
money plus 15% after a year that' be 115
Grand so 1 year 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 after
10 years 400 Grand not that much but
this is this is where compound interest
works it kind of suddenly builds it
suddenly goes huge 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
now you're on 1.6 million after 20
within 50 years over 100 million think
about that you're start starting with
100 Grand do you know what would happen
if you just left your 100 Grand in the
bank it would shrink with inflation it
would become worth almost nothing over
time but loan it out and work it and use
compound interest if you're 20 years old
now or or 30 years old now and you've
got 100 Grand and you did that that's
100 million you'd have within 50 years
now 50 years is a long time I'm not
suggesting for a minute that you should
um be one of these people that just have
a business plan that means when I'm 18
then I'll be a billionaire cuz what
about now today is a good day you want
to live life now so that's why I think
you should do things like deal sourcing
and rent to rent and lease options and
brrs do things that are going to make
you money now but once you've got all
the money that you want and you're
living a good life then start thinking
okay now how can I rescale this and
what's the point of being a billionaire
anyway for me the reason I I want to be
a billionaire is not because the money
itself I mean gez like that doesn't I'm
sure Elon Musk isn't excited about
making a few extra pounds next month
because it will affect his life in any
way it won't the thing that drives me is
just playing the game and winning and
being the best version of myself I can
possibly be let me know your thoughts in
the comments I'd love to know your plan
to be a billionaire or even a
millionaire if I can help you in anyway
I will see you next time